bismillah alhamdulillah assalamualaikum
greetings a peace
welcome to the Deen show and would you
like to have all your questions about
Islam answered at your disposal where
you can go ahead and log on to a website
call a phone number and get those
queries get those doubts cleared up well
ask a Muslim is where you can go and I
have the president of ask a Muslim
Shaikh doctor and what one Salam
alaykoum how are you how are you sure
I'm the lover Ottoman little oh let's
get into the what what's the the primary
goal of ask a Muslim calming it's kind
of in the name getting people to ask but
how did when did you start this and what
was the because I'm gonna and and and I
want you guys to stay tuned because
we're gonna get into some of the tough
questions that are thrown out there at
Muslims and trying to belittle Islam
attacked their last and final message of
problem ahamed his marriage to Ayesha
you're gonna have you're gonna answer
this but tell me first what motivated
you to start this organization I think
the very first important thing is we the
kind of prompt us to start its
organization is the fact that people are
calling going into all sort of people to
know about Islam people I mean if you go
to the news media they they ask X&Y so
they could so they could get the
knowledge about Islam so we started this
organization for the hope that people
would ask us about Islam and ask a
Muslim addisam asking a real practicing
Muslim how they go about their life how
do they practice Islam you know and this
is going to be I mean with them they
will get real answers about what Islam
is all about
instead of going to maybe the 700 club
Pat Robertson Fox News come to the
Muslims and again Muslims one who simply
does what Jesus did submits to the will
of the creator not the Christian there's
a big one that they throw out there they
say look Muhammad peace be and blessings
be upon him he was you know married to
Aisha it's such a young age they throw
the P word out there at him and how do
you go ahead and answer this this what
many will perceive as a tough question I
think this is an easy question but
why because we have to put things in
perspective the main thing the main the
way we go about answer this question is
by looking at two things there's one we
have to look at it from the historical
context and also from also you wanted to
also compare it to what other religions
and cultures have done back then the
very first thing is we tend to go to the
very the very facility we tackle is
what's prophet muhammad sallallahu send
them the only person who have done such
thing back then or deceased and out in
this action or there's other people who
have done the same thing was this is a
normal thing that existed at his times
and this is the kind of thing that we
tend to a man did go back to history and
time after time you will see the same
thing happening over and over there very
for the most common example that we tend
to utilize and this is something not on
the Quran not in the hadith this is it
could even easily anybody could look at
in the in the Catholic Encyclopedia
where it says you open that Catholic
Encyclopedia and it tells you that
Joseph it was 99 years old when he
married me when he married Mary who was
12 years old
so the same thing is that is it do we
consider this could we throw out the
p-word at them of course not because at
that time they had a different it their
culture allowed it the other thing is
that you know the another important
thing that we tend to look at is is was
this a foreign concept to the culture of
the Prophet Muhammad Allah is Allah the
any the enemies of Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him have used all sort of
tactics to to call him out like they
called him a musician they called him
you know for you know they called him a
liar but they never ever called him
somebody who who who you know goes out
with girls or something like that they
never used that against them even though
that could be an easy tactic to be
utilized I guess Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon them so that's that's another
thing even nowadays in in the United
States you'll see many states who are
the minimum age for marriage is 12 and
13 and 14 years old so if it's if 1400
years ago it was okay
you know it was not it was okay we still
some states still think it's okay even
right nowadays another important fact
that we there we tend to also minimize
in 1980 in the state of Delaware in 1980
in the state of Delaware this is the
United States of America you know the
minimum age for marriage was eight years
old you know so it's it we can't be
doing doing double standards here saying
this is all you guys are wrong but the
same token we are practicing here in
this country you actually talked about
this in one of your guys video you
mentioned st. Augustine and 350 married
at the age of 10 King Richard 7 years
old
Henry to 8th you mentioned this is you
talking about this as six years old and
you mentioned the Bible in numbers 31 17
it says say for yourself every girl or
every girl for yourself so this is even
the the British Catholic canons allowed
the British Catholic canons have allowed
the marriage of minors until the late
the early 1800s and that but later on it
made it they made an edict or a fatwa
against it and and this is now not
permissible so the same thing here I
mean plus you know another another
important fact that is when I wrote the
Aloha and when she made Prophet Mohammed
she was not a minor she at that time she
was she was mature you know people at a
young age back then used to mature
easily not nowadays somebody could
become 30 or in stuff that he's not
mature it's no play we play with video
games but back then because of the
temperature because of the the culture
because of the type of food that food
that they ate they were easy to become
for them to become mature at earlier age
that's a good point so even his
opponents at that time they never
brought this up and if you're gonna go
ahead and bring up something you have to
find a valid reason was it against the
law at that time so put it in proper
culture was it against the law was it
against God's law was it something that
went against the culture you what what
on what grounds are you rejecting you
you can't there's no
and then the founding fathers of this
country you mentioned Delaware it was
actually yeah the age seven and then you
mentioned also the New Hampshire New
York Massachusetts is twelve on the
books thirteen in New Hampshire so you
would actually have someone who goes to
Mexico let's say there it's what is it
14 or something then that person goes to
Italy or another state so as soon as he
flies out of one place or another he's a
criminal
right I mean Senate President there's no
universal law that says you know this
this this is allowed the certain age
allowed in this country which is another
country so therefore we when we compare
things we cannot compare apples and
oranges we have to look at the
consideration the culture we have to
look at the consider in the religion we
have to get a kick into consideration
you know even the atmosphere what that
was localized at that time yeah and
again we're talking about 1400 years ago
this is a thousand four put things in
context or try we're put it in its place
and I think anybody was sincere open
mind would clear these prejudices that
they might have they would see that this
is not something that they can really
attack him on and even his enemies like
you mentioned who attacked on every
other aspect that they tried right they
didn't go ahead and use this and she was
actually a contract to get married and
it was his best friend that had allowed
this to happen
of course the other thing is this is
something that we again don't take one
piece out of the puzzle and say this is
the puzzle Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him have taught us I mean the he
taught us the morale of this religion
you know and he as he as he said in
Arabic luckily Dean and hula-hula Javed
Enel higher to eat each and every
religion there is a moral they are known
for such a moral and moral that Islam is
is known for is the is the morality of
higher being shy so how could somebody
who could teach us to be shy to be
humble to look down to lower our gaze
not not to mix with other with other
sects you know not to shake the hands of
a foreign woman yet his I mean you clan
his
he's doing these kind of things it would
not make sense whatsoever yeah that's a
good point in Islam being on the highest
level of protecting chastity morality no
fooling around hanky-panky with Gilda
it's all in marriage right the moment
has to be average immature you today you
have to obey the law of the land you
can't you know do opposite but we're
talking about the culture at that time
don't try to take it out and judge him
when others at that time they didn't the
law God's law the culture his enemies
they didn't attack him on that what
grounds do you have and then you gave
some points even from the Bible even
from history these people who are looked
at as Saints you gave those great
examples I think this is a case closed
shut what do you think I think so too
so again if if you have a question you
the best thing the best thing you should
do is try not to take what we think for
us is allowable in the 21st century
though I'm back to what happened 1,400
years ago you know now we have engines
back up in the used to have camels you
know now we have refrigerate back then
they used to put salt on the meat so for
a tip to be preserved so it's not we
really cannot compare the apples and
oranges for sure now anyone has any
questions ask a Muslim you came to the
Muslim you did a great thing instead of
going again to the 700 club
or to some Islamophobe you coming to the
right place tell us before we go you're
also feeding the people you're in the
community helping the community
spreading purpose and peace and also the
food that's true I mean this is part of
not being a true Muslim a true Muslim is
the one that does not just talks about
Islam and and there is action that they
have to be some sort of action Prophet
Mohammed be stuff I don't have taught us
that none of us a true believer unless
and he cannot be a true believer and his
neighborhood or his or his neighbor is
hungry so part of being good Muslim bar
part of being you know interacted with
in the community we have to look out for
the people who are poor or needy and
therefore this is one of the things that
little we have establishes we have to be
part of the community we have to
we have to feel their aches you know and
I mean there's something that we cannot
close our eyes on the poverty in the
community so therefore ask a Muslim have
opened this door to the poor and needy
to help them to help them if they need
anything they could come in and get
their you know weekly or monthly supply
and this is this is part of our you know
do the up toward them you've been back
giving back to the community Muslims and
again and non-muslims given to all of
humanity because we're brothers and
sisters in humanity calling you to
worship the creator of humanity the one
God the same God that Jesus Moses
Abraham all of them call people to
worship the warning garden if you have
any other curries any other questions
ask a Muslim calm we'll see you next
time please be with us on ik it is
important to understand things in their
historical context first us will be
silly to ask what kind of smells that
they drink 2,100 years ago
or to ask what kind of engine used to
have back then therefore one must
understand that things for 200 years ago
were very different from that time have
changed and so human have 1,400 years
ago it was very common for women to
marry at a young age it is a historical
fact that girls from ages 9 to 14 were
married off in Europe Asia Africa and
America for example San Augustine 350 AD
he married a ten year old
king richard ii 1400 AD he married a
seven year old Henry the eighth 1500 AD
he married at six years old even in the
Bible it says but say for yourself every
girl who have never slept with a man
according to Catholic Encyclopedia Mary
the mother of Jesus was 12 when she
married 99 year old Joseph before 1929
the Church of England ministers could
marry a 12 year old in Britain before
1983 catholic canon law permitted
priests to marry off price at the age of
12 a lot of people are unaware in the
United States in the state of Delaware
in the 1880 the minimum age for marriage
was 7 years old and in California too
was 10 years even now the marriage age
for some states are 12 in Massachusetts
13 in New Hampshire and 14 in New York
at the terms of Prophet Muhammad
the poem those who refuse his message
tried every method and strategy to
discredit him they were always looking
for opportunity to attack him verbally
or even physically some of this verbal
abuse consisted of calling him musician
or a soothsayer or crazy however they
never thought to point out or objected
to his marriage to Aisha why because
this was the normal society meaning it
was completely normal with that said did
you know that prophet muhammad peace be
upon him he had only one wife Khadija
throughout the first 54 years of his
life did you know that she was a widow
did you know that she was 15 years older
than him he peace be upon him spent his
entire youth with her he was committed
to her until after her death by keeping
ties with her friends what about Aisha
was she a child when she agreed to marry
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him first
it's important to note that it is
strictly prohibited in Islam to marry
someone before the age of puberty note
the age of puberty varies throughout
different times and different places
according to scientific references girls
might enter full-blown pretty early
anytime between the ages of 9 and 15
also the average temperature of the
country is considered to be the chief
factor with regard to administration and
sexual puberty so was I shot a child no
she was not so what about the wisdom
behind this marriage God always knows
best the marriage of Aisha was an
instruction from God I should air it to
us more than 22-hundred Hadees or
sayings of Prophet Muhammad display upon
him Asha was the exceptional intelligent
and since she made Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him at a young age she was
able to learn so much from him she later
played an important role as a teacher
expert and interpreter of Islam so there
was so much wisdom behind this marriage
for those who do now don't probably
support him
Prophet Muhammad this woman who did not
come to seek worldly pleasures but
rather he warned us against them his
companion described him as a man of
morality and said he was shyer than a
virgin in her seclusion
when the believers asked him in an
awkward question he would cover his face
out of shyness he taught us that each
religion is known for a kind of morality
and the morale of Islam as shyness &
modesty put innama ana
mysticum you have in a Yahoo Camilla who
were seven can usually para be - yeah
Mohammed and slowly ha whether you
should be rebirth at you not be here i
hada say I'm only a man like you
whom revealed to him that pure God is
one God so whomever would work to meet
his Lord let him do righteous work and
not associate anyone with his Lord if
you have a pushes about Islam as Muslims
you